you know one of the things that you
maybe don't want to say if you're trying
to convince other people about how
cognitively stable you are is to make a
completely outlandish claim like doctors
who gave me a cognitive test were
shocked at how well I did on it
that's essentially exactly what Donald
Trump said to Sean Hannity on Fox News
the other night during the same
interview in which he failed to answer
the same questions from a few weeks ago
a second time so let's look at the clip
and then discuss it he didn't mean that
because he hasn't taken any cognitive
test because he couldn't pass one I
actually took one when I very recently
when I when I was you know the radical
left was saying is you all there is you
oh there and I proved that was all there
because I asked it I aced the test and
he should take the same exact test the
very standard test I took took it at
Walter Reed Medical Center in front of
doctors and they were very surprised
they said that's an unbelievable thing
rarely does anybody do what you just did
but he should take that same test but
now he has been totally taken over is
the constant bragging about really odd
things wearing anybody else down and
there's a lot to break down here but as
usual aside from from Trump lying all
the time when Trump goes hyperbolic you
can be extra sure that he's lying
doctors were surprised rarely does
anybody do what I did on a cognitive
test what and the whole context of this
is that the right is trying to frame Joe
Biden as having dementia we on the Left
have had concerns about Trump's
cognitive state for years and we don't
know whether it's related to cognitive
decline in the form of early stage
Alzheimer's or dementia side effect of
some prescription medication drug use
there's a lot of many many different
ideas going on and there's many examples
that point to this the verbal glitches
that coincide with the shoulder spasms
Trump not recognizing Rudy Giuliani when
Giuliani was right in front of him Trump
talking about the oranges of an
investigation Trump getting off of Air
Force One in front of his car and
wandering off and having to be brought
back by a Secret Service agent
having to be helped down the ramp after
his West Point speech dozens and dozens
of these and what they're doing is try
to turn trying to turn it back on Biden
saying Biden sounds lost he doesn't know
where he is he's hiding from the
campaign trail in his basement because
of cognitive decline Biden recently said
I'm fine and I've been tested they
reacted by saying why would Biden be
tested for cognition and yet now Trump
is saying I've been tested and I did
incredibly well on my cognitive test he
even was given a lollipop on the way out
and was able to get a second scoop of
ice cream that night what test is he
referring to first of all we don't know
if Trump is referring to the Montreal
cognitive assessment as far as we know
he got that test a couple of years ago
this is a simple test 30-point test that
takes ten minutes it's really only good
for identifying very serious issues with
basic memory recall an executive
function and just being oriented in time
in place so the 30 points come from for
example the clock drawing task you get
three points I would say to you draw a
clock and show me what the hands look
like when it's 6:15 that you get three
points for that copy not even draw from
memory copy a three-dimensional cube
that's a point I would ask you where are
we right now and what's today's date
that's 20% of the score you have to
identify three animals okay so if that's
the test Trump is referring to he took
it a long time ago and it doesn't really
tell us very much claiming to have aced
it is like saying you know I aced a
colonoscopy right like these are
screening tools for serious cognitive
decline and it wouldn't rule out any of
what's being explored with Donald Trump
now to go back to I took it recently at
Walter Reed that's actually a part of
this that's not being discussed as far
as we've been informed Trump hasn't gone
to Walter Reed for medical evaluation he
was there recently I think visiting
troops but he hasn't been to Walter Reed
for medical care since that day last
year when he was weirdly rushed there in
Walter Reed said we didn't know
he was coming and what we were told was
oh he had a few hours free and we
decided to go and get him a jump on his
20/20 physical it wasn't believable then
but as far as we know that's the last
time Trump was there and as far as we
know he didn't get the Montreal
cognitive assessment that day it was
actually back in 2018 or even 2017 so
none of it makes sense none it's all
very concerning and again doctors have
never seen anything like my results on a
cognitive assessment it's the hyperbole
that immediately signals that Donald
Trump is lying let me know what you
think is behind all of this and remember
that you can get the David Pakman show
audio podcast for free this is available
to everybody every day on which ever is
your favorite podcasting platform if you
use the iPhone podcasts app beautiful if
you're on your desktop computer and you
like Spotify perfect it's available
everywhere make sure you're subscribed
for free to the daily podcast to get the
full show every day right around 3:00
p.m. Eastern almost all American
journalism is controlled by a few
massive corporations and news voice is a
one-of-a-kind mobile app that tracks the
bias and corporate interests that infuse
the news stories we consume every day
and it's totally free to use it's a
great tool to have on your phone news
voice is not funded by advertisers or
corporate investors the platform is
supported by contributions from users
like you the news voice app will have
some really excellent new features soon
specifically for the 2020 election but
they're wanting to expand their team of
independent journalists in order to keep
everything running they're offering
special rewards to anyone who wants to
give to their new Kickstarter campaign
which can be found at news voice dot-com
/ kik giving a contribution will come
with rewards like insider access to
group chats with news voice staff
members as well as access to a variety
of special features go see what news
voice is all about